Now by The Shadow business secretary
Jonathan Reynolds Mr Reynolds it's good
to see let's talk about nurses Gavin
Williamson Matt Hancock so much to talk
about
um I wonder if I could start with nurses
do you support their strike action look
nobody wants to see a strike take place
but it's a reflection I think of the the
state of the NHS after 12 years of
conservative government I think if the
government is willing to engage and
listen to the legitimate concerns that
nurses have got there's a chance to
avert it what I would worry about is
they'll play it like they did the rail
strikes played for politics not try and
resolve the dispute try and essentially
exacerbate it so they can present that
as the problem with the NHS when
everyone knows it's how the NHS has been
run I think crucially I heard Stephen
Doyle talk about pay earlier and
obviously that's a part of it it's also
about workload and if you look at
Labor's plan which is to abolish that
the non-dom rule bringing over 3.2
billion pounds and use that to expand
the NHS Workforce to address those
concerns about workload that is the kind
of thing nurses will want to hear
they'll want to know there's hope for
the future that there's a plan for the
future now we've got that that if the
government were willing to adopt that I
think they could go some way to
resolving this dispute do you support
strike action well I'll support anybody
going on strike to improve their terms
and conditions but what I'm saying is I
think there's a way to avoid this I mean
this is the first I mean there were no
strikes in the NHS under the last Labor
government I think this is the first
strike nurses are even contemplating
pretty much ever so it tells you how bad
things have got that they've got to that
position people have got to listen to
them politicians the government have got
to listen to them but I think if they
address workload and pay as our plan
would do I think there's a chance to
resolve that what about seven million
people that are waiting for a
non-elective procedures well
that again is a sign of how bad things
have got I mean the level of waiting
lists and and our expectations of of
when and how long it should take to see
a GP compared to 12 years ago I find it
astonishing and it's actually so
significant it has become I would say
one of the biggest economic problems
facing businesses and facing the country
because you've got so many people not
not in the labor market not able to take
a job and do work or return to their job
because they're not getting the care
that they need so this is more than a
health issue this is about the overall
impact on the economy and I think most
patients will understand that everyone
in the Health Service is working
extremely hard work extremely hard in
the pandemic and still is but they they
can't do everything unless the
government's willing to acknowledge
those burdens and put in the kind of
investment the extra 10 000 nurses and
midwives we would we would have every
year that the doubling of District
nurses extra Health visitors that's the
kind of thing they need to hear unless
the government changes how it's run the
NHS there'll be no solution to that
um Gavin Williamson's had a proper
kicking over the last few days but
wasn't he just doing what Chief whips
are supposed to do in other words
keeping MPS in order no and I I think
the idea that this is how politicians
should behave or do behave is wrong I
mean there's no way he shouldn't
obviously it isn't wrong because that's
what he did there's no way he should
have been appointed to government I mean
this is what three appointments and the
three prime ministers and three
resignations in disgrace it's terrible
judgment from the prime minister to put
him in whilst he's under investigation
but for me this is you know why would
any prime minister do this well that's
because that's the conservative party
today you've got to do deals with the
likes of Gavin Williamson and swella
Bradman if you want to be conservative
prime minister and that is why they are
incapable of the stable Effective
Government that everyone wants to see in
the UK yeah but I I again make the point
that as a chief whip you have to keep
MPS in order don't you well you don't
keep them in order you've got a whip is
simply how do MPS collectively caucus
and make decisions as a group as a team
it shouldn't be about personal abuse or
threatening people or revealing things
about their their personal lives and the
idea that's what it's about is a
caricature I think but it appears that
you know in some cases maybe there are
conservative MPS who think that's what
it's about the job of Chief if I would
say is to listen to MPS to feedback what
their constituents are telling them and
help make better decisions in Parliament
as a result and I don't think that's
what he was engaged in plenty dirty
laundry in your party though just
looking at a list compiled by the team
this morning
um April Liam Byrne cabinet ministering
Gordon Brian's labor government
ostracized
um and then member of his constituency
staff October this year Christine
Christina Reese bullied allegedly
members of her constituency staff again
in October married male labor MP
reportedly facing the investigation in
the House of Commons over a sexual
harassment complaints this month a
member of the Scottish labor government
accused of taking part in online
bullying so there's bullying on both
sides look I'd say the difference is
certainly under Kia stamina's leader of
the labor party we've overhauled our
disciplinary procedures there is action
taken when anyone commits wrongdoing and
proper investigations take place I think
that stands in stark contrast to what
we've seen from Rishi Sonic which is
frankly appointing people he already
knows they're under investigation and
failing to address those issues head on
I expect high standards of all
colleagues in Parliament but where
people do transgress on the labor side
there's a clear effective system in
place I don't think the other side can
say that yeah although Tom Watson um
should he be moving to the House of
Lords no I think there's a there's a
thorough process that assesses any
application for the House of Lords Tom
is a former deputy leader of the labor
party so I think yes that's an
appropriate Avenue for him and his
appointment to that is the right thing
to do I'll be doing this concerned
speaking to your Shadow Home Secretary
yesterday she was saying that she wants
to know know what advice she was given
where are you with that well again why
are people like swella Braven and Gavin
Williamson appointed to government it's
because the Prime Minister Rishi Sonic
has to make these deals and do that I
think there are major question marks
over the conduct of the Home Secretary I
find it frankly absurd you could resign
from government from a position because
of your own wrongdoing and then get
reappointed to it in a matter of of days
and I think that the motion we had in
Parliament yesterday just trying to get
some transparency around this I think
the reason the government resists that
is the more transparency there is the
worse the position looks for them um
would you support the suggestions in the
papers this morning that the highest
rate of tax could go up to 50p in the
pound is that something that labor would
support well look you've got to look at
any of those decisions in the context of
the financial information we'll get in
the Autumn statement what I really
object to at the moment is where the
government flies a kite every day you
know they're cutting this they're
removing that they're going to change
that we can only make those decisions
when we see the information that was
denied Us in the mini budget and which
led to the chaos which has crashed the
economy and cost households up and down
the country well I need to know what the
fiscal position of this country is
before I can say yes or no
put forward well we yes the damage has
been done it can't be easily reversed I
absolutely accept that but I think
serious countries make decisions based
on transparent information and
information about what Revenue any
measure would raise or what the cost
would be of canceling certain things and
I think frankly what we're seeing at the
minute is a level of uncertainty caused
by the government over the last 12 years
as well as the mini budget that is
actually getting worse every day you
know every day we might not build
nuclear power stations we might not
build hs2 the country cannot cope with
this level of instability businesses
need some certainty to invest and if you
if you haven't got that from government
we just don't get that every day you
can't make serious decisions so we need
to see the proper information then we'll
make those decisions how do you feel
about Matt Hancock going in the jungle
you know being a member of parliament is
a job and it's a privilege and it's a
serious job now it's lovely to be
something like the shadow business
secretary getting invited on a show like
this or being able to stand up at the
dispatch box in the House of Commons but
if you're anything in Parliament that's
still a privileged position and I
absolutely object to what seems to be a
general view across a lot of
conservative MPS that it's not in itself
a job that you could be the former prime
minister and base yourself out of
America rather than be the MP for
Uxbridge or you can go on a national
television program whilst being an MP
you know it it demeans politics and the
job that we do and those people like
Hancock should remember it's a privilege
to be a member you'll be watching him
I've never watched it I might tune in to
see a little bit of it which I suppose
is is the effect that they wanted by
putting someone like Matt Hancock in
there I won't be watching it
heavily but I'll probably have a look
and see how he gets on will you vote for
him having to eat crocodile anus I I
think there'll be a landslide across the
country for for my being volunteered for
that kind of thing